Nikki Glaser's here I think that Nikki I
mean I also if I were a guest on a show
would probably leave the buffer between
myself and Jim North I love Jim I want
to be I would I would wanted to be close
we actually would like you to I said no
it can sit up with us if she wants to do
because she's on your show that's sure
of course no it can you know they used
it up there no I know it can join us
Noah is of course the producer on us
yeah which is on every day after our
show over on Comedy Central radio
channel 95 yeah right after this I'm so
happy to be here thanks for having me of
course thanks for coming you doing a new
schedule sergeant would you like doing a
new schedule what do you mean like time
you start 1000 time yeah it's it's great
it's like the then I feel like
accomplish you know the feeling you've
done you've worked already and then
you're done in the morning done you you
can be a piece of [ __ ] the rest of the
day and still be like oh I got something
done yeah I love it
I have the rest of the evening to
realize I'm failing and every other
aspect of showbiz right what do you do
after this do you go to the Jew go to
the gym after yeah so then you have that
accomplish and then what do you do after
that like you spend a lot of that's like
yes
Monday Wednesday but you get naked and
tweeter your nipples for several hours
yeah there's a lot of a long time yeah
what do you do with your day yeah it's
you go back to sleep or no sometimes
yeah and my 10:00 a.m. isn't as rough no
it's not yeah but it's yeah it's not I
can get a good night's sleep but I don't
yeah i'm nap sometimes but i'm depressed
and so i just like i said why am I
depressed yeah I just think um I don't I
really don't know I
my thoughts are bad and I and I have low
self-esteem and it's definitely that
yeah you know are you in a relationship
no tell you're depressed mm I think I'm
not in a relationship because I'm
depressed
everyone wants to be like I'm like
complaining all the time why I don't
have a boyfriend it's like why would
anyone I don't even want to be around me
it's a bummer I got to fix myself first
when you let the right women it's
whatever
right yeah I should get back into
therapy I was when if there be for a
while and then I just stopped doing that
but it seems like things are going well
do you get to a point where you're like
saying everyone's like you're Sarat
you're like
blowing up things are great and I'm like
I'm that makes me even more scared
because the better my life get I'm not
happy it's like this isn't working right
ever I think he's making me happy isn't
because things are going good
career-wise because before you can sit
there and go in like how if I just had
some mainstream attention then I would
feel better about this and everything
would be okay and then you get it and
you go oh no everything's still exactly
the same yeah right I you know what
makes me happy now I was like trying to
figure out like what really gets me
going and it's like getting hearing back
from a guy I like that's the only thing
that elicits like a true happy response
in me the other day like a guy wrote me
a texted me back that I've been waiting
to hear from and my friends were like
we've never seen you like to say like
we're videotaping me they were like
recording me cuz they're like we've
never seen you so happy and I was
watching the footage and I was like I
look like it's the same it's the same
smile that I had when I was like
Christmas as a child I haven't seen
myself that happy I was like me finding
out I was going to Disneyland and it's
only I only get it momentarily when I
get like a text back from a guy no you
sent him a text and you were afraid he
was only about you I just there was a
guy that I've been like trying to just
bang like I just think he's so hot and
I'm hoarding him
yeah please we don't like this kind of
course for this early I know you're not
used to the nine o'clock hour according
this young gentleman and I've been
wanting to be courted by him I see no
one knows the whole story he was on the
he was on the show we were like friends
who is he I don't want to say but he's
like I'll tell you off air no is he on
the show super hot guy he's a comedian
no no what season he was on your show
yeah yeah like no okay all right what
does he do just stop is your dancing
partner from Dancing with the Stars
that's Nikki Bella fell in love with her
dancing part listen everyone does she
left John Cena for him if you're gonna
leave John Cena for somebody you got me
yeah what happened yeah why she's not
with John Cena and she's with this
ridiculous dancer and I'm like I want a
terrible choice John Cena
I'm not kidding you that's what this
show does it
you are so intensely involved with
someone so intimate it is it's it's wild
I I knew all the stories about you're
gonna fall in love with your partner and
I got kicked off the show immediately
and I still was like feeling things not
even for my partner but like people
other I like had kind of a showmance
going on with other people in the show
that were experiencing the same thing I
was going through is just it's just a
traumatic experience and it's your whole
life and so if you try to connect it and
keep it going to the contactee because
you kicked off the show and I was like
kind of fooling around with another
person on the show and as soon as I got
kicked off the show it was like no this
is over we were we were only sharing a
connection because you were still on the
shows on that show now I keep now I have
to keep he he had to keep going you know
right yes working got kicked off at
first yet don't please don't pull up any
of we're just gonna see what the cast
one of these people it was Artem wasn't
it he's a charmer me was my partner he's
so hot but he was married but they're in
good shape dude they are the hottest
people a lot I was Artem all they do is
work on their bodies that's all in there
they're all peaking physically or else
they wouldn't be on the show they get
they get taken off the show as soon as
they age out even a little bit there
they are physically perfect specimens
and they're all model like Russian
models slash ballroom dancers so it was
it was heaven so I was dating someone
issues during that show she'd probably
[ __ ] her dance partner a hundred percent
if you're listening don't it and you
have a person that is everyone on that
show we know the public ones that have
like now John Cena or Nikki Bella and
our damar together I'm not kidding you
everyone on that show is in love with
their partner at some point really do
you think the dancers fall in love with
their partners too or they know
sometimes yeah they know
the score but they can't help it you
can't help it you were holding someone
for four to six hours a day
oh yeah it's like that is gonna cause
you to fall in love even if you don't
want to I'm not a good dancer like you
think Jeff Ross's dance partner once
told me that he had he couldn't it was
hard for him to recuperate like the
feelings he had for his dance partner
it's hard to get over she was okay with
it yeah it's intense I think Jerry
Springer was in love because Jerry
Springer he back in the day like he was
on one of the earlier season yeah and he
desperately wanted to get voted off the
show cuz he's too old it's not
physically in shape to do that but they
nobody would vote him off
hey I just had to keep coming back and
coming back but I wonder if he was in
love with whatever young chickadee he
was with yeah probably there was
definitely something sexual tension
there's always something unless you just
shut down there's no way that there
isn't I would never if my boyfriend went
on that show I would be like we're on a
break for however long you do this until
you get out of the because you also know
it ends after the show it ends after the
show I can't keep going and I know there
was someone else doing the same thing
it'll be too much yeah oh the second you
start I mean Nikki Bella passed it
because he's still gonna do the show
right yeah well he was on the show this
past season with a blind skier who okay
right so he was saying I mean like yeah
it's it's if you
I don't want Nikki Bella dead I will
just say to you that I know that there
are certain people on the show dancers
on the show whose wives will be like you
can't have that partner because I don't
I don't want that to have really yeah
and it's not like you know I don't this
is what happens it is guaranteed and
it'll be an attraction it's just like
doing a movie where you're have love
scenes a bunch of people on movies
that's we but we all know this like
they've all fall in love with each other
there's so many romances that you don't
even know like mr. and mrs. Smith [ __ ]
that goes down that you don't destroy
you just try to manage so you mean to
tell me this door is born you think they
were physically intimate together oh my
god
Dicer Lady gaga daddy I I guarantee you
I'm and that's what I was looking for I
was I was I was dying to go in the show
and fall in love with someone and did
you um I didn't fall in love and I
didn't like him I liked him a lot
attracted to what now you've got this
other guy who does your show we don't
know a mystery man does your show
yeah and you're like oh my god I have
feelings for this guy now yeah that
they've developed before the show I was
like come on the show Oh drats
but it was just like a flirt it like
yeah like let's take this to the next
level let's hang out more my element
where I'm like in charge like guys love
that I'm the worst at like no one wants
what I'm put throwing out I talk too
much
I'm too sassy and brassy guys want the
guys I'm attracted to want like a quiet
traditional woman pretty push your
careers going really well now which is
intimidating for a guy because how many
guys have that much going on you know
what I mean sure I know do you think
they're intimidated by you and I'm like
well they're not intimidated enough to
like hurt me and then make me want to
destroy them and so like where's the
intimidate they they are attracted me
enough to like get get me going and then
they then they ghost me you have really
a lot you know how they goes to Jim how
can I do I want what Jim was use you you
tell which one the male one no I was out
I was what I thought was a date we're in
the middle of dinner in the steak place
and she goes this is just platonic right
we're just gonna be friends no she was
um I guess I was too old for her which
was fine I was like yeah I do [ __ ] it
dinner all right fine
okay so we hung out at dinner I was okay
with it and I'm 50 so I'm like I don't
give a [ __ ] what about the one over text
we said like what about the one over
text who you were like it wasn't there
I'm actually you're trying to figure
where to eat about having that on stage
now actually yeah I will read you the
gist oh yes this really is a this is
pure ghost this one was a [ __ ] I think
respect we have been talking back and
forth a lot for like three days and it
was going well I thought I met her on a
hinge she was a real piece of [ __ ] okay
because it was so none reasonable like
we have been talking yeah so I said to
her where do you want to eat and I feel
part of the city and she said the West
Village started perfect we can find
something between both of us maybe do
you like steak and she said no I don't
eat meat so I were okay fish and that
was the last that rehearsal the
proverbial blocking on the app on the
phone and on the [ __ ] on the sidewalk
you laughter that's like I'm 50 you
could have just told me you weren't
interested no different kinds of meat
stations [ __ ] douchebag
good to common fish a lot common thing a
lot he will eat fish there pescetarian
sure that you were being like yeah yeah
I was what a [ __ ] huh after three
days living I got a lesbian joke I've
heard that a lot though that where
you'll be going back and forth with a
girl and then out of nowhere they just
stop and that's kind of what has been
having they disappear I had this one so
I was supposed to go on the they were to
go I guard let's I'll we'll figure out
where we're gonna meet and she doesn't
get back to me at all the next day she
goes I'm so sorry I've been out of sleep
this whole day I think I had food
poisoning because she blows off the
night we're supposed to hang out so
night just give it right back so I go so
strange because I must had the same
thing I said right after i text you
yesterday morning I had to go to the
emergency room had to get fluids and I
shut my phone off for the next two days
so and I figured you were getting in
touch with me so I don't I feel I'm not
happy you were sick but I'm relieved I
didn't leave you hanging I feel way
better today so I just came to write
back I said the same thing I rejected
you by the way yeah yeah then she goes
three days later that's good did you
have a good day today and I just ignore
what that's like
I had the same thing like three days
later after after three days she goes
how was your day today
then you wait three days and say good
you yeah unacceptable this this new
thing of ghosts I mean just beyond it I
don't know I are we owned an explanation
for why people suddenly yeah there's a
rudeness to it I mean again I've done it
so I can't be civil it's only fair
you've got a piece of [ __ ] for decades
yeah I've goes to people before sure
what's so easy now it's like does it
make you a bad person maybe but do you
have to deal with it no if you haven't
met them you can just stop texting back
right this camera has decided like if
you start talking to someone new and
you're like I'm not even into this idiot
anymore that I was texting with on riah
like who cares I don't need to write
back to his last think of how was your
day that's fine but if you've gone on a
couple dates with someone and they're
asking to hang out again you owe them
something of like hey I just don't think
this is gonna work I'm talking to my ex
again whatever it is did you connect on
some level at that point right yes
there's some kind of human connection
happening yeah you owe it I went out
with a girl a couple times she was
really attracted I was very attracted to
her but after the second time I'm like
it was a get-together guess you know I
don't think I want to do a third date
and I was annoyed but I was like eh she
was onto sorry alright take care like
what can I do it is what it is there's
too many options now yeah why sure she's
too young and too hot for me and so she
did the right thing right so but you
finally found your happiness when this
guy texted you oh my god dude it was
like so this is the thing so I I liked I
met this guy I've had a crush on this
guy since I saw him on my TV many many
years ago I was just like that guy is so
hot I couldn't even verbalize it because
I was watching the show with my
boyfriend at the time I was like that
guy is and the guy like we he he came
across in the show not great and so I
couldn't have if I was to ever have said
to my boy ever link he's kind of cute
like he would have been like what is
wrong when you watched my TV was he
attainable wait what when you watched
him on TV was he at a no no because you
weren't there yet so hot he's not
attainable at all that's but now you're
at least talking to him I mean like yeah
well that's why he come off as good on
TV what did you wrong um he just was
like a little bit villainized in the
role that he was okay the reality show
right that's it
because when it rolls if he was playing
she didn't say character so it should
like your trailing eyes on the show
reality TV show bachelor The Bachelor I
wouldn't if I wouldn't be surprised if
it was the bad 17 just think about it
how many reality shows is Nikki watching
you know within the last year's The
Bachelor I guess that we're on a Nicki
show so I know just out of curiosity do
sir on a radio show right so now we've
print some of your favorite guests from
the yeah right well anyway okay so I
don't you know what I don't even care it
doesn't make you find out I don't care
but I clearly don't care because you're
not telling us what did you text him for
him to touch me
this is what happened is like we we met
on Dancing with the Stars he was not on
the show but we met like that's the
first time I met him I was like oh my
god that's like I thought I saw this guy
at craft service one day when we were
taping the finale and I was like that
guy is so that looks like blood you know
the guy I was like why is he that he
wouldn't be here thats just a crew guy
that looks like him okay so hot then I
found out it was him and I'm like oh my
god like I gotta find a way to like meet
this dude or just at least make eye
contact to see if there's a spark there
wasn't I definitely do
he had a flirty line when we first met
but he say well we were taking I was
like I gotta get a picture with you guys
cuz there are all these like guys
shirtless guys hanging out bachelor X
bachelor contestants and I was like I
gotta get a picture and he was like um I
think we need to pick you up right like
that's what you want right like you we I
think we should all pick up Nikki like
he was the one that was like we should
like do something sexy when oh yeah it
was a none of the other guys made that
attempt but he made Nikki's Twitter and
Instagram because he's one of the guys
one of our photos
just so many people that I know yes so
then like Becky own he he asked me to do
a thing that he was doing and I was like
oh he just wants like he respects me
comedic Lee that sounds just all these
[Laughter]
he looks up to me
because he's not a comedian like you
know they he thinks I'm funny and mean
and whatever he want he asked me to do a
show I didn't know if it was like
because I want to get to know you more
or because I want you to do this thing
with me because you're a name or
whatever and I'm Palin whatever so I did
the thing it wasn't that flirty then he
comes on my show it is a little bit
flirty after he does my show not on air
at all and then I'm like oh my god
it is this guy just want to be friends
and just want to be like partners then
he asked me to do a podcast with him he
called me and was like hey I want to do
a podcast would you do this podcast with
me and I was like I don't think I can
but like is this guy trying to get like
do it full-time not just one absolutely
do a podcast together right and I was
like man I would love to do that because
it was it would just like it would be so
fun to like flirt with this guy and have
like a little romance going and then I
was like I can't even do it so um and
then I but I couldn't tell if he what do
you want me as like a bang all I don't
want a relationship with this guy just
one have sex with him because he's hot
and I want to be validated that this
really hot guy that I think is out of my
league whatever well what if he blows
you off after the first time I having
sex that could be devastating
yeah and I'm that happens a lot but I
think it's worth it because he's so hot
like I think right I know that's what
I've determined was it was worth it
it's better it's better to have [ __ ]
and lost than to have never [ __ ] over
her Instagram trust me she would never
help anyone right track yeah she doesn't
want you on the right track why don't
you just throw it out there and just say
like hey let's get together I'm
interested you look let's [ __ ] so that's
what happening like that right we we
spent a lot of time talking about like
ha it's so I invited him to go to the
cellar one night when I was there and he
brings ugly Troy thinks it's Rob Thomas
but that's mainly cuz Troy's obsessed
with Rob but he's a great singer
songwriter yeah can you find a picture
of Nicky being picked up by a bunch of
guys either on her Twitter or Instagram
he's distracted by Rob
it's your I would if you find it yeah I
didn't post it so you're not gonna find
it on there so um but so then he he came
on my show so then I eventually was just
like when am I gonna find out if this
guy likes me or not like is there any
traction he's watching my Instagram
stories there's a little bit like you
don't watch someone censor grant stories
unless you're interested in that it's
just that's a thing yeah finally I'm
like I can't live like this any whoa
this was the moment we matched on Riya
we matched on the Lord quote/unquote
dating app is he I swiped right on him
and probably years ago I've been a riot
four years off and on I think years ago
I saw him and was like look so excited
waiting for that match to come through
it never came through I'm like I guess
he just never got to my profile yeah he
definitely did and just didn't like me
but now that we have a rapport the other
night I get a match and I'm like I don't
even pay attention to it you get matches
on right you don't care and then I get a
message instantly and it says message
from first name and I'm like and I'm
with my friends and I go if this is who
I think it is if this is I'm gonna lose
my [ __ ] because this is finally
validation that it is him right here
i'ts this is very exciting news Nicki oh
I have never been so happy in my life
as this I was like I'm assuming this guy
this is gonna happen he's definitely
into me man that's it that's an end to
me 100% yep so then I just wrote back
yes it is didn't hear anything
didn't hear anything being cool a week
and a half didn't hear anything yeah
that's a long time to be cool that's too
long really cool yeah he's like actually
ice-cold maybe I maybe had food
poisoning
I lost patience yeah after about a week
and a half and I was at the cellar one
night and I there was another hot guy
there and I was like you know what I
mean
care about this one I'm just gonna burn
this to the ground if it's I need to put
it out there so I was just feeling
flirty and fun and I shot off a text to
the sky to like really put it out there
like hey what did you say it's so you
should share wait'll I tell you I I was
so nervous about talking to this guy
that I enlisted the help of my friends
Anja Marina and we'll sylvans there's
nobody I want what I have a dialogue to
write then we'll sill then well I use a
great writer she's a songwriter she
knows how to use words single for like
20 and and will she's very like why
could you why'd you ask those two is
Mike the homeless guy not available it
was the worst thing I could have I just
needed help and I was and they actually
will had some good lines so this is what
we came up with for the first sign so
because I had been at the cellar with
him he had come to meet me before at the
cellar mm-hmm one night when he brought
a date you know a supermodel date oh
that's good which by the way my friend
like I was there with my friend he
brings in this supermodel and I told it
before he walked in I go I don't know if
he's here alone or with a friend mmm he
walks in with this like 24-year old
[ __ ] gorgeous model my friend winged
woman's for me and talks in the model
the whole time we him and I are like
really hitting it off we go that was the
first time I felt like oh there's
something here right yeah fell off
almost immediately after that but so I
write to him I'm at it's so lame all of
this is so lame I mean I don't stand by
it but I wrote um I'm I'm at the cellar
at our table our table that he brought a
model like art what okay I'm at our
table what's your ETA
he lives in LA there's no ETA it's just
a way to flirt and be like our table
what's your ETA right he goes while I
live in LA so it might take me a minute
and I go no wait if you lose in LA the
reason he hasn't responded for a week
and a half is cuz he's gonna hit you up
when he's back in New York I know but I
just want some sexting I want to send
some naked pictures and I want to
masturbate to some stuff I see okay
stopped masturbation my mantra actually
okay I honestly like that's I know
nothing can happen but let's just get
the sexy wheels a spin in I understand I
think Nikki wants more from this guy but
she thinks that have exactly one thing
she yeah I think she wants to be a
relationship she does I do but not with
this guy they would not work if you HOT
he's too hot and it's just like we he's
not into me but logically he's not into
me I'm just saying that to soften the
blow
sure because logically you know it's
probably not the greatest idea but you
know you want I wanted to I think will
reject me to like me so yeah yeah I
would love for this guy to be like I
would love to be in relationship with
you that is never he's not even watching
my main squeeze
what were you want you know what though
sometimes I was on Instagram and those
are girls talk to you back and forth
she's beautiful and we were joking about
her coming over and cooking because no
one's ever cooked in my apartment before
and she said she would that was like oh
[ __ ] I didn't think I had a shot with
her yeah and then she's like saying that
she wants to come over and cook himself
then she goes to be yes she did she goes
to completely stop did you buy the food
soon no I just asked her like when she
wasn't wanted to come if that guy
brought a date to the cellar to see
Nikki he's I don't think he's that
interested
no he's kind of like hey alright if I'm
around you want to [ __ ] that's how
that's right I know that and and he is
but doesn't mean that Nikki wants like
me she still wants more no I she knows
that it's not gonna happen no it's I
really do
I would love to just be able to have sex
and have it be casual especially with
this guy like he's not like a penis he
just doesn't he this guy knows how to
[ __ ] tell us on tight pants when he
came on the show yeah I mean look you
can see no look at the bulge what did
you see now when you look I def pecker
checker
I just sense I get that big dick energy
or at least like I know what to do with
my dick energy he knows what to do I
know you notice like you noticed a bulge
yeah I mean you did there was something
in that package oh yeah yeah he's he's
so he's so hot it's ridiculous so yeah I
would girls you day
what's that I noticed your thank your
comment so um so what happened
um so then things got bad so at first he
writes so then it's flirty and I'm like
oh my god this is on we're gonna be
sexting by the time I get home and then
I'm gonna be able to like orgasm tonight
with Venus I said ever yeah I'm like so
excited and I am bouncing around this
I'm like skipping around we are back and
forth and onion will are helping me and
we're writing back flirty things it's
kind of cute and fun then this dude
shows up that I have been at a flirty
Instagram relationship with a comedian
okay from not the United States shows up
at the cellar
Jimmy Carr not for the United States it
doesn't Ruffini from Brito exactly
Rafina from brazil we were we had been
like flirty texting a year ago right
yeah that's it oh I like you yeah he's
he's hot and in person oh my god I was
just like he shows we have already have
texted flirted we never met in person
finally this guy shows up I'm literally
talking to onion will about what to
write next to this guy and then this guy
testing on the shoulder and I turn
around he's like this six foot seven
gorgeous Brazilian man who's like Nikki
and I'm like oh my god we we already
have this flirty connection I mean it
was our it was already in motion Grande
words there he's a very famous comic in
Brazil it was really big guy yeah
so he's so nice and and and suddenly I'm
like oh my god it's so good to meet you
finally like and were and I'm like
distracted by this hot guy my friends
are like what do we write back to him
Nikki he's writing what do we write back
and I just go write whatever you want
because I quit because what was I gonna
do cuz I wanted to like still keep this
in play the guy that is in front of me I
couldn't be like hey I'm texting with a
hot guy and my friends are helping me so
I just go kart blunt write whatever you
want rookie mistake you should have done
this you should have taken the phone
back and said be right back I'm going on
or hold on going downstairs
yeah I have to [ __ ] it brings out all
the time I got your [ __ ] yeah no I'm Big
O Dottie in my underpants right
yes a girly sorry B RB RB is a big one
right
BRB Turtles leaving Michelle gotta go
instead I was the cool I was just like
do whatever you guys want and they're
like really and I go you've done a great
job up into this point I'm cool with
what just text him whatever take over
truth about cats and dogs
you're my Janeane Garofalo like just be
me and I didn't even care that I was
like I don't even care if I lose this
guy because this guy is so hot right
sure
I'm distracted in the moment I see
within two texts we've lost him no I'm
not kidding you
completely lost him what are the new
tags okay so at this point it's like
flirty it's um me to skip let me just
read it to you this is so devastating I
I still I get I cringe thinking I'm not
letting you okay
so so I go well he goes well I'm in LA
so it'll take me a minute and I go
should we reschedule and he goes can we
thanks for understanding my Google Maps
is all screwy today I said I'm here this
weekend do you have ways I'd try that a
little fun flirty with direct shore and
topical cos ways is a great app great
great way is super topical very
connection I know I'm here this weekend
he goes LA and and then he goes on to
say something about some something that
he he complements me by insulting
another comedian you know how that sure
it happens I watched this thing when I
saw you I laughed harder at you that's
what he said okay okay
I laughed harder during your set but it
but the thing I did watch was amazing he
so he complements my whatever but he
said I laughed harder during your set
I'm that's Kiki sentence I don't like
that I don't mean that but that's just a
key size of course that then will so
Vince comes up with the idea with Anya
while I'm sitting there talking to this
new hot guy we got to do something with
the word harder he said hard we gotta
work harder take it from zero to one you
are like you were like a you know of
maybe at a level 15 out of 100 and then
go to like 68 oh no I want to take it up
and like get sexual right cuz it's just
flirty and fun up to this point her and
my whole philosophy with dealing with
the guys is like never ever give them
any like always be the last two texts
they have to come to me like I'm tired
of chasing dudes yes Zach what they put
and I did reach out to him first so that
was a little rough my game but this is
completely derailed my whole mission and
I've waited months to make a move with
this guy and it is it is blown in one
text really well then there's two would
they say okay so he said but I left
harder at you right
Oh aaww thank you exclamation mark yeah
blah blah blah the person he was talking
about is funny
why would I say you're right they're
funny I love a hard laugher I want I
want to die I love a hard laugh he
didn't write that no one wrote I love a
hard laugher I love a hard laugher will
wrote that yes Ben - terrible thank you
yeah she's really funny I love a hard
laugher - - why don't you take a quick
trip to New York City and oh how
embarrassing that was so they send that
off I don't even know what's been sent
cuz I'm still dogging this guy nobody I
just look at that text like I might text
with a child like this doesn't this kids
it's [ __ ] gusting it's horrible so
then he writes back I mean the ball is
dropped because until then it was
question question you know when you're
talking to someone you have to ask a
question - sure yeah you come to New
York City why don't you take a quick
trip to New York City and he raced back
I was just there I was just there no
period I was just there and this is
devastating this is devasena let's say
his name is Jeff okay just GE Oh F so
then this is what they decide to write
back are you suggesting I come to LA
no there no there is no indication that
he is suggesting that suggesting I come
to LA Jeff and put his name in to really
like make it personal that's like if you
say to somebody hey do you want to go to
dinner and they go no thank you and you
go are you saying you want lunch
Disko what no sex you said hey do you
want to get do you want to cuddle and
watch 911 document suggesting I fly over
there to you and come see you in LA when
I get a chance he writes back nothing no
way he wrote back no nothing I'm not
kidding oh my god in Fort like it was a
dialogue there was he was sitting on his
couch he's wasn't doing anything this
wasn't like we were from a little kid in
Christmas to just right back he
depressed Nicky and like I wanted to
I was I was devastated when was that
this was at the cellar on last Tuesday
so I would text him back and say hey my
friends picked up my phone when I was at
a set and I was embarrassed and he let
me say really physically intimate with
the comedian from Brazil no not not even
they won't even believe what that guy
did to me okay so then by the time that
this is all happening it's so
devastating to me that I can't help but
bring this new hot guy into the mix and
be like okay listen what just happened
yeah we were all laughing it was fun it
was like kind of like and and I was
being cool back because I was like this
guy's so hot I don't even I was like
laughing at first rate like I was just
like okay it didn't really devastate me
until I got alone and I looked at it and
I was like oh no but we were laughing
about it with this guy and the guy was
the next morning what is his name Rafina
anjineya a Rufina
wrote to me so did you ever hear back
from Jeff and I go no but I don't really
care I'm trying to be cool and I don't
care like whatever trying to be cool
Nikki Glaser and and he's like Oh cuz I
woke up like worried about it that was
like it was such a
thinking I was like I know but who care
whatever and then I asked him a question
because we were in a dialogue never
asked him I said are you gonna argue at
the cellar tonight or something like
that which he he was he's like if we're
not talking about your drama I don't
care he he did the same thing that that
guy did to me and totally dropped the
ball and we were supposed to hang out
that next night we had like the night
before we had been like okay it's gonna
be at the cellar tomorrow tomorrow you
will show vents text blue both of them
they really did it just atomic bomb any
anyone near you just destroyed any its
it was devastated out was getting that
guy on the hook and like building up
something so we can maybe have sex
someday mm-hm and it's completely heard
back from him he is definitely written
to me on my Instagram story you know you
can reply to a story he's trying to
reestablish that were friend good we're
going back to lay one Jeff would say
Jeff wrote to okay so I posted something
about a article about Emily Ratajkowski
you know the model sure and she the
headline was Emily defends the fact that
her boyfriend doesn't pay rent and some
article like that and I was like that's
a goal I wrote something like this is a
career goal of mine is that someday I
have to issue a statement that my
boyfriend doesn't need to pay rent I pay
for it was just a dumb thing and he
wrote back to that this was nearly me a
year or something like that it was he
just wrote some dumb comment and I was
like does he mean that he wants me to
pay for his life I will like I was hate
reading and do it and my friends like no
he just means that I don't know if they
had nothing to do with me only me I was
banging a model who was paying for my
rent is jumping back to talk to you then
he wrote back they call you pal
oh my god and then he wrote that nice
Graham bud yeah I posted something else
in either's for hahahahaha to it and I
did I just respect horrible and then oh
and then I posted another picture of me
and the friend that were there the night
that he brought the model me and my
friend Elna
I posted a picture of us at the cellar
and he wrote back who's she
let me just see what he wrote he wrote
something like those are my girls or
something like that oh he wrote the team
the team like that's the team and I
wrote a quad that's a good one
the team the team like it was just like
ah that's that's the girls that I knew
for like the his one night at the cellar
that was who were sitting across from
the team and I just wrote you were
missed never responded to it this is not
good confirm it all confirms those
feelings of worthlessness doesn't it all
confirms is that I'm just never gonna
get but like I I realized like why do I
want him so much because then I went to
Todd Barry's birthday party after the
devastation at least take the sadness
out of sorry Todd Barry aged more than
watching Todd Barry get older all you
had to do is just keep talking to it
so Todd goes I'm telling Todd the story
and I'm like I'm devastated right now I
had this guy in the line it was gonna
happen and now it's gone and Todd goes
oh really
okay what let me see this guy and I
showed him he's like okay so what do you
like about him and I'm like I like I
don't he's hot right it I literally I
just want to bang a guy that is that I
feel is so out of my league so then it
validates me as being oh I'm hot it's
all about this like I just want to be
validated as hot and it's so empty and
can't what for validation another I
don't have a crush on a guy you have a
crush on just want to have really good
sex that's all I want
what if they what if you do have sex
with him once it's not that good and
then he completely blows you off then
I'll talk about it on air and it'll be
fun they'll be late about it he has a
little dick and he's afraid that Nicki
will talk about his small penis never
talk about your small penis I would
never do that I would say that you
weren't like if you hurt me I'll come
after you about like how you hurt me but
I'll never make fun of a guy's penis
ever ever tried to no yeah no you can't
help that but you can help how you treat
me and I'll come after you for that
forever
yeah I will I
if you hurt me I'll be mean to you about
the fact that you hurt me but I'll never
I'll never insult a guy's body no no yes
well I got what Jim you would like my
vagina a lot let me just say why it's
growing a dick when I used to listen to
you as Jim on air talk about how
attracted he was to vaginas like that
you described like you yeah I always
just you were the 400 me like okay got
some guys fetish eyes this I love it I
wanted to be a complete mess but how do
you feel about like the top of a bus in
Tel Aviv [ __ ] how does it make you feel
though that Jim's his proclivity for
large vaginas has just morphed all the
way into just penis like a big [ __ ] it's
not that I just a lot of like you know I
like a lot have time like I've now that
I've talked about it on Co I've talked
about it extensively she'll send me
pictures and be like which one is yours
and I'm like it's not that [ __ ] up but
it's it's it's definitely enough where
I'm like I don't see it represented in
porn as much as I'd like no let me get
self-conscious about like the lips are
too bigger in that you know there's you
shouldn't I I don't I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm I'm I've had nothing but nice things
said about my vagina but I didn't have
sex for years cuz I thought guys would
like to look at it and throw up on me
and leave like guys talking bad about
[ __ ] is preventing them from getting
late because girls never want to show
you their vagina if they hear you going
to lose Nikki I'm worried you might have
self-esteem issues yeah I mean I'm just
as we talk I'm starting to think I want
like a marionette
I love it controls my arm one more Jim
and Sam catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the SiriusXM f
[Music]